des dizaines de restaurants sympas
autant de galeries d'art des bars
branchés des gens beaux et bien habillée
d venu apporter mène pour l'insecte pas
que les homards nous voulons montrer au
monde qu il y as c'est vrai il y à un
raffinement qui attire les gens qui veut
habiter ici et c'est nécessaire pour
notre avenir
poids plume est une petite ville
soixante six mille habitants pourtant
elle est devenue la destination chouchou
des hipsters un endroit très cool
fondée par les britanniques au xviie
siècle elle prospère à l'ère victorienne
car elle profite de l'essor industriel
manufacture usine
la ville est d'ailleurs parsemé de ses
grand édifice en brique rouge
c'était difficile il n'y avait pas de
travail
les gens ne voulait plus vivre ici le
directeur du musée fait référence à
l'époque des années 80 90 alors que
c'est l'hécatombe
les industries ferment la ville est
déserté triste pauvre un endroit parfait
pour les artistes de new york et de
boston qui ont trouvé alors ici des
ateliers pas cher paris 14 oct
aîné de l'art et la culture sont des
vecteurs de développement dit il et
c'est exactement ce que se sont dit à
l'époque les autorités municipales qui
ont financé c'était sens artistique
le musée l'école des beaux-arts les
galeries le gouvernement ici ils
disaient ah oui on commença à voir
comment ça se passe
que ces lézards et les choses que tel
qui attire qu'aucun des gens de partout
dans le monde viennent ici pour cuisiner
c'est fascinant qu'il y ait autant de
talents culinaires dans une si petite
ville on dit ce jeune chef venu de
l'origan car la renaissance de portland
s'accompagne d'une conséquence
inattendue
la ville est devenue une sorte de mecque
d'une gastronomie qui a trois
ingrédients principaux le local le bio
et l'innovation et la ville ne veut pas
s'arrêter là
oui nous avons créé un programme pour
attirer de nouveaux résidants qui
deviendront les clients des artistes dit
le directeur du développement économique
de la ville
une version 3 nous voulons attirer des
gens qui travaillent dans des secteurs
d'innovation et reconstruire une
communauté plus jeunes
pour placer futurs immigrants par clint
s'est dotée de rues piétonnes et de
pistes cyclables et cette opération
séduction semble marcher
ce qui est marrant c'est que nous savons
que c'est un les gens de brooklyn
la plupart des gens c'est les jean de
bournay work
donc il ya quelque chose qui attire les
gens de boucles à new york
émilie dubreuil radio canada portrait